let's see
we're gonna go into more of the the how
and the why of training
so that your practice has a kind of road
map a kind of orientation
but you must be careful
that you're not
chasing the priestly or the academic
concerns so as you remember
i was academic and i realized
um that
it at first is very interesting and it's
very helpful
but it is its own kind of culture and it
has its own kind of
capital and then your own kind of
investment
and eventually it has its own kind of
motivation and it takes you away
from the experience and so i
gave you a kind of very simplified
cultural theory
uh to explain what i've lived through
um so that you can be on guard against
it okay
so in
my field was the history of religions
and
what i tended to see was that you always
had
uh this experience
this realization a very individual
like or individualistic
subjective experience
that happened or realization and
eventually
that tradition it becomes a tradition
as it becomes social so that person
will now meet someone else they want to
have this
a realization and it starts to become
social
and as that happens you start to see
a displacement of the experience
for the method okay
and you start to when you have that
displacement of the
method over the experience
and you combine that and the only reason
you would have that
is because you have people who don't
have the experience
do you see and those people organize
themselves now according to the method
this is how you get dogma religious
institutions a priestly class
or caste something like that and
eventually you have
empty rituals or
dead dogmas and
that happens throughout history we're
not the first
uh era where that's observable okay
so i have the experience or the
experience sir and then just to simplify
things i
give you this priestly moment or priest
moment and so here's where you have that
subjective realization
and then here's where you have method
over experience
and out of this because it starts its
own kind of capital system made up of
actual material capital
but also in terms of symbolic and
cultural capital
uh and everyone's now playing that game
okay so i want priestly rank i want
priestly certification
uh i want institutional power etc etc
uh there comes a moment where you have
specialists
in the method okay
and that starts to produce what i call a
meta discourse
it's like i know i'm not even
having the method over the experience
i'm now just talking about method
okay i might not even do the method i
might
i have no experience at all in the
method i don't even go to church
okay i don't do the ritual but i now
can talk about it okay and in talking
about it
i'm wishing to cash in on that cultural
capital
symbolic capital uh you know because i'm
an expert in it and so this
i call an academic
phase okay and this is marked by the
production of this meta discourse
so this is the discourse now i'm talking
about the discourse
and that's a meta discourse
so you see that all the time this
is a cultural phenomena that happens
and it also happens and this is why it's
important for us
it happens at the individual level you
lose
track of what you're after
and you start to just become ritualists
or dogmatists
in many ways the experience will always
resist the dogma
always which is why a tradition like
zen will say it's beyond words and then
throughout zen's history
you'll have this
fetishization of language
and then a subversion of language is
like they went too
far so you have your koans which is a
subversion of dogma a subversion
of um the sutras
were going to operate outside of the
sutras but then everyone started
memorizing
the answers to the koans they started to
be recorded
and you had people now just repeating
them
uh and then you would have characters
like eq
who would talk about like this this is
stupid okay and he would subvert that
and uh you know his his act
of spending half his life in the temple
and the second half of his life uh
in love with someone and in living
in a whorehouse is him getting
past the method and back to the
experience
okay
you're going you have to struggle with
this individually
and the reason for it that is there's a
psychological reason
okay
these two aspects
are fed by the
ego tripartite
that we talked about before
and so they will speak to us more uh
succinctly more easily we will
understand them much much more
um they will
operate as we said last time through
things like fear
pride and ignorance
and they will also
of course function
through our will to power and this will
be manifested over and over and over
again
so when you have a character like eq
and you look at his act of
being very very critical
of the zen of his times to the point
where he just turns it on his head
he falls in love with the woman and he
goes and lives
in a whorehouse which is the exact
opposite
of the pure land that the temple
geography
was supposed to represent but
not if you are awakened you see
to see the temple as a purified space
or even as a space required for training
is a dualism and so he's
turning that on his head he's operating
outside of the dualism
and as simultaneously then
he withdraws from the power system
his rank goes away do you see
his title goes away uh he's
probably socially um outcasted
oh he gave up his vows oh he's the idiot
and then it wasn't until centuries later
through his poetry that he remained oh
he actually is the one that saw the
light and everyone else was playing this
game
over here why are they playing this game
because this
speaks to us this is this speaks to us
in the same way that when uke comes in
with aggressive or offensive energy we
resist it we push back on it
um and so that that is why
young young clashes are more prevalent
because it speaks to us
it speaks to us through our fear our
pride and our ignorance
or why external level levers are more
prevalent in aikido because it speaks to
us
or even why kokyu might appear easier to
gain as a skill rather than aiki because
it speaks to us it's operating through a
will of
power us overcoming whatever it is
that's in our way
why because i have this thing in place
and that's what it does man
right this is something else so even at
an individual level
you should be on guard
for when uh you're showing
obvious signs of this working so you
you're talking about what people talk
about in aikido
you should shut up okay
uh you talk more like this you talk
more about the method than you're
actually training you should shut up
you should get back to this
you should learn how to subvert all of
this
whatever method you give whatever
discourse or meta discourse you're using
you should know how to ultimately have
it make no sense
at all then then you're operating here
okay so we have to keep this in mind
both socially because maybe i'm
in this system over here this is this is
the only aikido i know
this is what i recognize as aikido i
don't recognize
the experience anymore
but i also have to be on guard against
because it happens at an individual
level because
this tripartite will
be more at home in these functions
i'm going to talk about the art i'm
going to think about the art i don't
have the experience the original
experience
what experience is that the actual
dismantling of this tripartite
i don't train for it i don't have it
i don't look for it i become satisfied
with these things
i want you to keep that in mind as we
talk about the
how and why for orientation reasons of
your training because
we don't want to go oh how and why
dogma and metadiscourse okay we don't
want to do that
okay all right
i think as a historian the main problem
to knowing the how and why of budo and
aikido
is the epistemic rift that has occurred
between
what we'll call pre-modern and modern
thinking
okay um and i've mentioned
it before so the pre-modern
epistemy is what i call concentric
in nature okay
and the best analogy that i can give you
is kind of like russian stacking dolls
the the doll is inside the doll is
inside the doll
and it is the same doll but it's also
not the same though
okay um
this thinking might appear to us to be
very illogical but in fact
it is a logic or reason followed out to
its extreme
and the place that you see this
most prevalent is in an indian
philosopher called nagarjuna
okay and he came up with uh he's trying
to look at reason
in buddhist philosophy and he came up
with this
uh what can we say about reality and
it's known as his tetralemma
okay so i'm going to represent it so uh
a a is a it is this is that
you can say that or this is this
we're going to represent that as a is a
that is one thing you can look at the
world and you go uh
that is a map a mat is a map a is a
okay but you're going to see eventually
that
a is not a or a equals b
so this is a map right but you find out
that it's
it's often much much more than that to
somebody so for example
uh you people freak out you have your
shoes on the mat
do you see uh it's more than a map then
isn't it
apparently it's more than a map okay um
and then once i allow for those two
propositions
um or you know so so here we are
matt isn't matt matt is not outside
do you see that that's a mat it's more
than a map okay
and then once i allow for those two
propositions then by a
reasonable extension um
you're going to have a
uh not to it okay so you're going to
have
uh a is not b so i had a is a
and then i have here a is not a a is not
a
probably better right and because i
allow for that
i can have a does not equal not a of
course
you see this is how you do it and then
uh what you're going to find is well it
is
it is once i allow that i have the
fourth logical extension
and then the thing is both so a
equals uh not a and a and
a okay so write this out in english
this thing is is not
is both and is neither
is it
okay this is the logic so you take those
russian dolls
and of course it's the same doll pattern
but it's not the same doll
so because of that it is both
the same doll and not the same doll
right
and because of that it is neither nor
you you go by extension
okay and so the way
why is this concentric is
like the russian dolls is how you
understand it okay what what is
the scientific epistemy the scientific
epistemy
is only the first two something
it is or is not and that's all you get
okay um why whoa whoa
what about that no no don't even go
there okay
but as you'll see even in uh various
realms of science where they're pushing
the thinking just like nagarjuna did
hundreds and hundreds of years ago you
start to get
this thing all the time so it is both
a wave and a particle it is neither a
particle nor a weight you see
because it is just reason pushed to its
extreme
okay uh but most of the times when
you're operating
as a modern you're operating at what i
would call a pop lever
level of the scientific epistemy and
you're functioning here
now why is that important to know
because this leads to misunderstandings
in my aikido
and i don't under it's not a technology
invented through the modern epistemy
it's a technology invented through the
pre-modern epistemy
so it's not going to just function at
here why
why is that important okay because this
leads to
um analogy
and metaphor
and that's how most of you understand
your aikido is through analogy and
metaphor
but the pre-moderns don't do that
um they're looking for this thing and
once i
have uh all four
reason conclusions
i actually don't have only analogy and
metaphor
but i have what is very important i have
communion
those four things are happening
simultaneously
like the russian stacking balls
they are a unified system okay
we don't want to understand our art like
this because this is part of this
we want to understand our art like this
because this is part of this
and i'll give you an example of that now
okay
so uh let's say he's gonna do ski and
here comes
a contesting energy
okay he's a and on b
so he comes in and then
we know in aikido through our dogma and
our meta discourse
that i should become harmonious with
that thing
okay but because i don't understand
things concentrically
it's more of an analogy or a metaphor
for harmony
okay it's not a communion so for example
as he goes
and i'll do that you see and now
metaphorically i am in harmony with him
because we're no longer opposing each
other
i'm now looking over there he's looking
over there we don't have
competing contestant views okay
so here it comes and i don't contest
and i move out of the way but i am
contested
you are you still have
b and a and this pre-modern
idea is going to be different i'm
actually going to have an av unification
or the neither norm okay that's what
that's how communion is going to be
manifested so throughout the religious
discourses of the world
you have systems that will recognize it
positively
it's both a and b and you have systems
that will recognize it
negatively it's neither a nor b but what
happens is the first two options go away
okay so as he as he comes in
and i go here and i i generate
uh my adhesion so i'm not grabbing him
because that would be a
and b so as as we're here
uh he he can't go backwards sure he
can't go backwards because
it just pulls him off balance and he can
go forward
and the reason he can is because i'm not
going backward or forward
you see and so we in the in the
internal ikea adhesion have become one
so i'm going to show you the difference
they kind of look the same so we go and
i'm going to do an external you see
but if you pay attention they don't
sound the same and they don't really
look the same
so i'm going to do the same thing with
the high key adhesion
uh and you can test for it now so if i
do an external thing
he should be able to either push through
or
pull apart because we are both either a
or b do you
get it so he can he can run through if
he wants
or he can pull apart any point in the
technique that you want
okay
[Music]
the way that uh most aikido people get
rid of that is they assign
him an external uh
additional task so when you felt my
young young clash which is him pulling
against my grip you were supposed to
stop
and turn back around do you get it can
you do that again
okay so he goes you see
and you can see uh the consciousness in
his turn
if you pay attention you can't see that
he turned himself
why because he was supposed to okay um
when i when i have the uh when i have
the
adhesions on him uh he can't
he can't turn apart he can't go any
wherever he wants
so as i already showed he can't go
forward he can't go forward
he can't and he can't go back okay
and the more he tries because of things
we're going to go into
the more the adhesion shows up so uh
it's a nature it's nature working itself
the more he tries to pull the two forces
apart
the more the two forces hold themselves
together it's the way the universe works
okay
so in fact if he was very very relaxed
and loose and was not at all
manifesting a he's he's like a
ghost it's very much much harder
to get a to be both b
or neither b okay because he's not a
strong a
he's not an a with a lot of integrity
but the more that he
he pushes uh the more he's subject to
uh what i do to his balance you see you
get that
so it's not an analogy
of of uh not contesting it's
actually a concentric unification of
a and b or if you want to pause it
negatively a and b disappear so it's
neither at that moment
he's not a and i'm not b or both
a and b equals the same thing it's how
you understand okay
so we go and uh
let's have it where um
he is going to play with what i'm doing
okay but i will never grab
okay to grab is to manifest b and then
i'm back in the
number two a does not equal b okay so
there's no need to grab
uh he's gonna do whatever see yeah he's
gonna
he's gonna move whatever so he can even
uh
throw the other strike if he wants it it
doesn't change
the relationship okay i might have to
move like for example
he throws that strike i don't want to go
like that okay
so he goes and i'm just going to do the
technique
and i'm not trying to do kotakaish as a
self-defense against
that stupid punch i'm just generating
uh the first aspect of the
tetra llama the first two aspects a
does not equal b okay so he goes in
i get the the uh communion
and uh he does whatever he wants to do
and i'll do my technique okay
you might experience that everything
falls apart because i
wait i can't get to the third and fourth
aspects of the tetralemma but that's
getting us further along
than when we were operating with just
analogy or metaphor
okay so we're going to be on guard for
this happening within us
and of course we have to be
self-reflexive that it's actually
happening
culturally socially so most of aikido is
at this level
right overwhelming because most of
my aikido will have a tendency to
operate at that level
there's not some sinister mustache
twirling person
that's ruining aikido it's just this
speaks to my
uh ego tripartite and so most of us will
do this
okay and so at an individual level you
must be on guard
so i'm going to give you some
information
that had on why and be careful
okay so in what is today
china going back to at least recorded
history so you're looking
at at least 500 bce
there was a notion
of how the universe
all creation all life ev everything
all so therefore including me
and therefore including the nage uk
relationship
and therefore the techniques of the art
everything
is of this same concentric nature
they're the universe just keeps
repeating itself
over and over and over again okay and so
this is how you get
certain understandings um
one of them is uh heaven
man earth
and that's what we want to go in today
okay
because our understanding of this
concept cannot be
one of analogy or metaphor it has to
include
uh this thing it has to be concentric
and i'll explain that as we go along
so we've already talked before how from
another discourse but and which never
contradicted this discourse they're all
just trying to say the same thing
we have that kind of numerology here we
have a kind of sacred geometry
but it's all discussing the same thing
it's people
in this class trying to
understand and explain to
non to people who haven't had the
experience yet
how you have the experience okay so
before we've talked about the dao um
and so there's just one thing that is
beyond all knowability because it is
beyond all duality
so it's void it's chaos it's it's
that okay and from the dao comes
uh the two things so i have this kind of
uh universal oneness
or again sometimes expressed in a
negative way
void this kind of zero-ness or this kind
of emptiness
and from that the two things come
and that's my yin and yang
and then my yin and yam and so uh will
break off into four four into eight and
it just goes on
and then numbers are given value and
that's how you get these numerologies
and again uh you you're going to get
specialists
on the discourse and you start to in my
opinion
this is what i mean when you made a
fetish out of the thing
now you're more conservative number two
i don't give a about number two
because in the end i
i have this one you see which is how the
experiencer would do it
it's the same thing like um
you know uh eq you're hiding out in the
whorehouse you're going to be
impure i don't give a about purity
and pollution
do you see he's he's gotten to the heart
of the matter
he's beyond purity and pollution it
doesn't matter where he's at now
the whorehouse is the pure land
so this idea here
these are a using of this
reason to explain how the universe works
so
the universe is going to function and
this that there's a
underlying totality to it of some kind
and it has to it's it has to
manifest itself in by dividing
into two and then these two things keep
going and going
um and so though the world everything is
split up in yin and yang so right now
when you have your
last technique of the ski
they have young energy you see and
when i caught out of the way externally
i did yin energy okay
but that is not a communion that's still
yin and yang existing so i'm still
operating at this level as i said
which is this level okay they're young
i get out of the way i stay here okay
and a lot of people think that's
the eye of ikey but that's not
okay the eye of ivy is happening here
so at a moment when we make contact
the yin and yang division goes away
and we become one and we return
to the natural workings of the universe
this pre-division thing
so we can't disconnect he can't pull
apart he can't push in
and we just get stuck communion happens
okay
why does it work because this is the
nature of the universe
i'm not doing anything this is just what
the universe does
and your ancient technology of these
martial arts
are based upon that when
whenever the yin yang is manifested
again as it was originally so
he punching me being punched
uh i am just continuing to function that
aspect of the universe
i the yin yang aspect is the natural
but so is this voidness this singularity
what we're trying to do is operate at
that voidness that singularity
the loss of the individual self remember
this experience
is a reconciliation of the subject
object dichotomy
it's a kind of ecstasy i'm kind of
outside myself meaning
i do feel me but i do feel him
and he feels like me like when i when i
was like what are you feeling dave
that's what i kind of feel and i don't
really
feel this yin yang thing it's not him
against me
or me against him or me getting out of
the way of him
do you get it so um
what makes this manifest itself
ego ego man ego manifested that
tripartite shows up so my fear
or my desire my preferencing manifests
the duality and the ego identity
all that thing starts to function so as
i try to throw them
i the eye shows up and the separation
happens
and so your art gets reduced to external
things
like you're just using fulcrum and
leverage
i try to be powerful i try not to get
hit
i try to get out of the way all of those
things
are manifesting the same yin yang
which is not this level of the art
which is this level of the heart
why does that speak to us because of
those evil reasons
but also because of
this is our modern epistemy this this
makes sense to us
this does not make sense to us it's
counterintuitive
the same way that your the theoretical
physicist will preface
his or her discourse with this is a
little hard to grasp because
he or she is going to be operating at
this it's not intuitive to us
but you know what it was never intuitive
to humanity
it was always a specialized
understanding which is why you had
people
like kung su lao eq
they're operating outside of the north
they're operating outside of that ego
tripartite
okay um
so let me before we go here let me give
you
an example of how
i can do what we would understand is the
non-contestation
you see but one operating at the level
of
the void versus one operating externally
at the level of the yin a yin yang kind
of thing
okay so we're gonna here so when i
understand the world
and the technique dualistically and i
don't
understand this underlying universal
principle where
the void is or the tao or the communion
or the union or the
negative or the emptiness that thing i
don't understand that
i'm not understanding the ancient
discourse which is
if you got rid of all yin yang you would
get rid of all contestation
and so therefore i don't once i'm
operating at the level of the dow
i don't have to reduce my technique
to external yin yang
displacements okay so for example he's
he's coming in and this is always going
to be
a matter of me creating an external yin
space when i'm operating
at an ego tripartite level so he comes
in
and i'm all i've moved out of the way
i've moved out of the way
um and so he he goes again and this
would be the opposite
i moved into into the weight so people
are going like
okay this is aikido move out move out of
the way
always yielding he's always trying to
get me and i'm always going to heal
or you know people are like well not
just overpower overpower
that thing this yin yang still you're
still at that level
the universe is still functioning at its
division
but because i don't have yin or yang
you can move out of the way as we just
demonstrated
or you can still close you can close the
gap
and it will not be the same yonko
it will not be the same young as that
so he goes
boom
[Music]
i don't have to go here in here
i can go inside okay and the same thing
push pull
and i don't have to do the yield either
i don't have to go this way
you can't go the other way because
everything
is is happening in that void i can go
anyway
i can push i can pull i can go up i can
go down
okay so uh this one i'm not move i'm not
going to do an external deviation
hit hard get hard hit harder
same thing so i i don't have to get out
of the way
go i'm not the same target but he goes
and i same thing i'm staying here whoa
let's
what we came to target though boom
[Music]
it's not just my sticking point so we go
hard harder hardest
uh this would be are you gonna do it
again
that would be a young manifestation
and you can see he's gonna displace me
because he has more mass and he has the
inertia
okay so he goes
that's not what i'm doing his energy i
disappear
and his energy is going into me
artist
you need to do
and i'm showing that because i can do
what would appear to be the opposite
of a yin tactic i'm letting him hit me
but
he's not hitting me as if i was young
as if i was contestant because my body
has been organized
outside of the yin yang division okay so
hence i can do small deflections
and i'm not he's uh he's pushing he's
i'm not contesting him the same energy
is going around me even though
i'm not getting out of the way so my
ikea does not have to be reduced
to defense or constantly retreating
and creating or maintaining distance
that's a yin yang world
what i want to do is function at the
level of the dao
beyond the two divisions beyond the top
two aspects of the tetralogy
and my technique can go backwards
or forward or even stay still
you see and so now the whorehouse is the
pure lamp
so we'll do these two techniques i'm
going this way
or i'm going that way
okay so i'm doing i can do both the
their parent okay so we
explained how different traditions
to their priestly class or their
priestly
cycle of cultural evolution
come up with discourses and we've
mentioned a
there's a numerological one and
we mentioned this kind of cosmological
one and we're going to
mention another cosmological one to help
us understand
okay uh and we want to keep we want to
keep in mind
uh those russian dolls that concentric
nature to all this
okay and then why because that's just
the nature of the universe
so as i as i manifest my
uh or as my ego
dualism preference
construct shows up as this shows up it
shows up because it's a natural part of
the universe and
i start to experience the world in union
young ways
but human beings have this special
capacity
this is how the discourse talks about
there's something unique to human beings
is you can function at the at the
universe at the
with the universe in that sense or
you unlike other things in the universe
you can function at this level too so
you can do your art
through some sort of yin yang thing
either my art is a young
overpower and a young or my art is i
constantly displacing and creating
distance i'm a yin
always in response to the young um or
you can do it at this level where
it's not i'm neither and i'm both okay
i'm here at this oneness voidness level
so
i i it doesn't look like i'm a target in
the sense that he hit me
but i'm not functioning like a target
does
you see it does i do
go back but i'm not going back in the
sense that i'm getting out of his way
do you see well i do go forward but i'm
i'm not going forward in the sense that
i'm overpowering him
okay and so my art is not meant to be
understood this way and so by
by doing my art in that sense i
am doing the aesthetic practice which is
what this
is the ecstatic practice of dismantling
the subject object dichotomy dismantling
the ego tripartite
and i the universe functions through me
now i become one with the doubt
okay that great void that's what's
happening
all right so now we're going to use this
kind of sacred geometry
or slash sacred cosmo cosmology to
understand okay
so um there was
some void there's some emptiness some
preform thing
okay and it's always there some great
potential um
it is often called the dow sometimes but
it's not
um and then the split happened
okay and that split happened and
uh it created a above and below so it
created
this world and the other world so it
the top part uh and that
is heaven and then the bottom part is
earth okay why the bottom part
part again why is kind of a weird
question because these are more just
maps of meaning they're not really
like we want to understand it in terms
of
instructional manuals where you got your
instructions
was with the person that had the
experience okay
you didn't just read a book you had to
go under a master
which is a person that was able to
dismantle this construct
reconcile the subject object dichotomy
and they would
help you do that okay but so be careful
because if you start seeing this as an
instructional manual
then you're going to start doing this
kind of thing okay
so um well
the the universe had to have heavy and
light
so part of it came down and part of it
stayed up
and the part that stayed up we're going
to call heaven and the part that came
down we're going to call earth
but you can understand it it's just a
split of that void
okay and then uh so here's my heaven
and then here's my earth and then in the
middle man
as i said has that precarious or weird
or just strain or special position
uh that you are actually functioning in
between the two
okay um
again you can look at uh buddhist
mythology
and and if you look at its reincarnation
models
it was only human beings who be who
could become buddha
you could you could be reborn as a deity
but and you might think that's better
but it's not better because the deity is
still subject to the yin yang rule
uh it's better to be a human and reach
buddhahood because then
then you're one with the dao or one with
the divine or what have you do
so many cultures afford this special
status to human beings
as you as a modern what i would say is
that
[Music]
your your nature is of such a degree
that you have one foot in the natural
world and one foot
under your conscious control and the
best way of looking at this is your
breath which is why breath
throughout history has played such a
prominent role
in religious practices so your breath if
you go to sleep you're not
conscious your body still breathes but
you can consciously control your breath
and also consciously you can see that
you actually
interrupt your natural breathing cycle
so through let's say a panic attack
there's nothing functionally
mechanically wrong with your lungs
but you're suffocating right or i ask
you to concentrate on your breath
and now you can't have the same
breathing pattern
this one went in at a level 5 value came
out at level 6 value went in at 2 value
this time
i got a 10 value coming out you know
it's constantly changing so
you have some weird status to your
organism that you did that pre-modern
man didn't see
other places it's not uh necessarily
ethnocentric or you know
go humans humans kick ass it was
uh an observation in nature so
animals and trees and things like that
would just
follow this natural cycle that nature
had for them they were almost innately
one with the dao but human beings had
this capacity
to so to speak fall from grace uh and
you could be it up
and and you're really subject to hanging
out there
and experiencing the world basically as
contests okay so
man had this central position and again
i talked about a sacred geometry
you you have these shapes
and just like the new when once a
priestly class
comes in and a meta discourse gets
developed
the values start to change so you
depending on where you look on history
for example yin is associated with
certain things
and you look another place time in
history after these two evolutions have
happened
and that thing is now associated with
y'all you get all these lists so
same thing happens here squares
associated
with heaven and one but man is now
associated with triangle
uh and and another one man's associated
with circle
we don't give a because we're not
going to do that game
okay we're trying to understand
something instead
so you get just for cool coolness sake
right
if if that's heaven uh and uh
early early early early what is now
china
religious traditions heaven had
uh some sense of also being
that doubt that divine uh that universal
god
and so at a certain point in history
there was no personal universal god
but early on in history tien was
a god uh like in the uh
like even in the sense of um
what is that tradition so above so below
it's eluding my name now
this modern tradition it's leading my
mind
i can't remember uh
they they have this sense that there's
this overreaching universal divine
principle tin had that understanding as
well
but even if you go into some certain
smaller virtues
smaller villages it wasn't only that
grand
scheme of things but well no it's like a
god there's a little statue that's
tien it's a little statue and i worship
the little statue so you get all these
variations okay
uh and it would go on and on forever the
high heavenly plane would go on and on
at
infinitum and so you just kind of
represented it with that square
and it preceded earth and what happened
is if i divide the square into
yin and yang sides what do i get
two triangles so that's represented on
the earth as you're going here
and then uh they the circle as you say
as we say you're part of uh uh
this weird thing of both of heaven
or the boy or the doubt but not um
you start to have like well a circle is
really when
when you take off the corners
and you're gonna have this uh shape like
that
and sometimes the entire system is
represented
you know and they'll put it all together
because
what is this it's just the nature of the
universe
it's just how it works okay um
all right i got that i can understand it
geometrically
i got that this is the nature of the
universe i got that i have some special
capacity
to either function at a yin yang level
or to function at a dow level
i get it but how am i actually
doing that okay well
again don't get stuck but
heaven is always pushing down
if i stand in the middle what's it
pushing down on
it's pushing down on me you see and it
pushes down
into the earth okay so heaven is
invisible
the earth is visible so this
model right here is representing
uh your internal arts so
the invisible pressure force whatever
i have two options that i can do
i can yin yang it you see so i can
contest it
or i can get out of the way of it or i
can
kind of be permeable so that energy
comes down
and goes into the earth do you see and
this
is the natural cycle of the universe
heaven is pressing on earth and earth is
holding up heaven
force is going to come through i don't
want to get in the way of it because if
i get in the
way of it the ego tripartite manifest
and i enter into a contestation with my
partner
so i either have to get out of the way
or i have to overpower
instead what i want to do is i want that
energy
their force of their punch to pass
through me
so when i demonstrated me flexing and
bracing
you saw the normal physics that you're
understanding
his punch displaced me and when i went
backwards
but when you saw me become permeable
his force went down into the ground
and heaven is pushing back on earth
and so his force invisible heavenly
force
goes through me and comes back out and
you saw him bounce off of me
okay um
this idea tying us more
into aikido
is in this practice
okay
so today in aikido because we're
operating at this level and very few
people have this experience anymore this
has come to mean something entirely
different
uh this is some sort of ritual you do
with certain exercises
and then somehow and strangely
as this tetralemma and this concentric
epistemy is thought to be uh
pseudoscientific or non-scientific and
hence mystical
and and by that we mean magic based and
just goofy false
people practice qikon kishin
with basically magic
as its underlying epistemology so i'm
going to do these exercises
and then in those exercises somehow
magically
i become more centered or my techniques
become better
uh you know so maybe i do it before
class
and hopefully that'll get my i'll be
able to stick to the person or create
a communion or manifest doubt you get it
but
and you go why why why ain't no one
knows why it just is because
it's magic
you just do it and then magically it
happens so strangely
us moderns are actually operating at the
very
level of thinking that we're more
critical of again this was
an extreme extension of reason not
a denunciation of reason okay so
what are these practices in reality so
chincon uh i'm going to use my terms to
understand it to help you get
here okay and no i'm not interested in
these
you tell them off okay
chincon is uh really
uh organization
organization of your entire being your
group so that includes your mind your
body
your thoughts everything your intention
your desire everything
all gets organized uh and then
so when i do that what is this
organization
it's the organization that allows the
energy
to pass through me and go on to the
other energy so
using this sacred geometry it allows
the uh heavenly plane to push down on
the earth
and the earthly plane to push back on
heaven i become
permeable you see and when i become
permeable and those two things are
happening happening that's when this
happens
okay so originally in uh these are
japanese words for these practice for
this practice originally
um they were done separately
and what but today in aikido it's one
kind of phrase
so i would do these body organization
practices and by doing those body
organization practices
i became permeable and then uh this
happened what did that what did this
happen what does that mean
uh that this is when the kami or the
divine
or this invisible outside things
uh is going to operate the way it
naturally does
it pushes through until it hits
something else
uh that it can't push through and so
this is where el sensei would talk about
uh kami possession or being possessed by
the divine
or becoming one with god but this
becoming one with god
is the very practice that you're doing
in your aikido training
all the time i am constantly organizing
my body in such a way
that that energy is able to pass through
me
you see and then i do one of two things
with it
what do you do dave you do the very two
aspects
of the universe itself the very two
aspects of the universe itself
uh uh one is i separate things or
i bring things together that's what the
universe wants to do constantly
it wants to okay these two things get
apart of these two things together all
those four things together those eight
things apart
right and those two forces uh
once once the energy comes into me uh we
call koku
is the separating energy this is why i
refer to it as projection
i'm separating the communion between uke
and nage between myself and the person
punching me that's when i throw them
um or i use that
internal passing through me of the
energy
and to maintain a adhesion okay
and that's why it is an adhesion i'm
bringing two things
into this togetherness okay uh
and just like kishin
is kind of uh passive
meaning i don't do it it just happens i
do the organization
and then the universe does what it does
the same thing
hokyu and ike are more passive
even if i want to assign one
and one yang there are more passive
things that happen
following the organization of my body
meaning
he will i will organize myself for his
energy to pass through me
and then he hits a coq uh
hard spot and then he gets projected the
universe does what it does
or uh he hits uh that energy
passes through me i don't do anything
more and the adhesion starts
and that's what you've been seeing is a
lot of the adhesion so when i
touch him and he gets stuck to me i have
organized my body
in a particular way that now he's stuck
to me when he punched me and he bounced
off of me
i organized my body in a particular way
and then
he hit the ground and he bounced off
into me
the universe separates itself
so let's give uh demonstrations
so uh
when i'm doing my art in that
sense of king kong kishi
i'm constantly trying to get that
organization
and then i allow those two different
energies to manifest i just become
concentric with the very workings of the
universe
i am the universe i i'm not fighting him
the universe is just doing its thing
okay
um so he he'll just come in
right and uh i'm doing that thing so i'm
gonna
again it's not difficult to see
or hear um because
there's other energies at play than the
external ones
and it's just like if i was playing a
guitar or a wind instrument
um if i touch the outside of it
i put another energy and i'm going to
change the sound of it
and so um same thing happens here
if you if you pay attention
there's more baritone
things like why would he flip over he
doesn't have a choice he's going forward
uh and around me he he uh is not turning
on me so do that same one turning
and he turns the other way and you see
he's not doing that uh so we're just
we're now going to go
in just a ji and the reason for this is
um to do a ching pong kishin you're
doing it all the time in kihon laza
but you ultimately want to do it
spontaneously like the universe
functions okay not through form alone
so uh you can just do whatever
[Music]
i'm just doing different things of that
and it's key that your uk doesn't
doesn't ever stop
his energy pass
any candy with external movements
it can't be really deep movements
and of course
but the more that you
[Music]
do things and the less positive
it is probably the less you're doing it
meaning if i go and i
push and pull and turn his arms
i'm probably not doing it
easy okay so playing with this
again organized
[Applause]
our practice is just acidic
constantly doing that
[Music]
hey